[Music]
are your kids into video games because
that's something that mine are just
starting to get into and it's like an
obsession yeah yeah well my son can't
get enough yeah i mean if we you know
and we do
you know our whole we try to keep it to
them you know all things in moderation
except the wine yeah um yeah
that's a deal no but we you know we uh
but he was begging for
the thing where it gets tricky is i did
a voice in a video game
like one of those um shooter uh which
one i'm not clear but i i it was uh
your work means so much to you yelled a
lot it was like the world war whatever
call of duty one of those yeah yeah yeah
and my son was like uh uh really one of
the game
and we broke down we said we you know
and what's what's curious about the
whole thing is you get asked a lot in my
line of work about the violence and the
video game and should the kids be
playing it and it's very difficult for
me to answer that when my son is at home
playing a violent shooter game and i'm
in the game
encouraging him
[Laughter]
to shoot people
it's your voice yeah dad it's awesome
you and i yesterday uh you're like you
know i mean i'm in there going 2 o'clock
fire
fire 12 o'clock
[Laughter]
good shot kid
and then i come in i'm like turn the
thing off let's go it's time to read a
book and he's like you were just telling
me to kill people
well killing time's over so now it's
time to read let's talk about it
confusing when i uh when you first came
on the show uh
i i hadn't seen justified and uh after
the show andy richter said you you got
this this andy breaker not the other
indirector he said you got to watch that
show i started watching i got hooked it
is an absolutely fantastic show and i'm
just curious season four coming up
what can people expect
first of all thank you very much and
thank you you're welcome
and thank you
um
uh it's a first of all it's a great i
appreciate that and it's a great season
wow we're just uh it's a it's an
impressive season what can i tell you i
don't want to give anything away yeah
you don't want to spoil anything oh the
spoiler
the writers they work so hard and
they're so talented like your writers
they work hard you don't want to ruin it
for anyone i don't know but i'll give
you a little something
it's okay please have seen some of the
stuff we cut today
america you didn't get to meet zippy
smiles
really good band saw zippy smiles and
that's all i have to say
conan chop chopped it
any hoots back to the show ashley it did
his odd that that made the cut ashley
sailed right in that might be yes
thanks i just want to make sure we're
clear
you're a dick
and i mean that in the nicest way oh
that's how i took it yeah
so
oh uh season four that in your
prospector voice yeah i tell you you're
a dick
yeah
[Applause]
this is a show we're so close
it's about to happen i mean it's
happening it's happening uh wow
i don't know what you're gonna do but
what are you guys gonna do oh yeah yeah
you're gonna be uh the grandmother i'm
the wise old lady that answers the phone
hello
they're
[Laughter]
yes solving a crime leave me alone
you've got cucumbers on your eyes yeah
just remember you were here when it
happened you were here when it happened
congratulations so season four anything
i i don't want you to spoil something
i don't want to spoil anything you know
uh the season i can you know the basic
gist of the season there's this big case
uh it's a big deal
my ex-wife who's pregnant with my uh
child that's a big that's a big thing
that hangs over the
but i'll tell you a little something
tomorrow night's episode
uh
the scene
where um
my ex-wife is shot and killed watch in
the background
there's a hot dog truck
now i don't want to say but just the
that is going to pay off
i don't want to give too much you just
said your ex-wife
in tomorrow's episode gets killed i'm
sorry yes
that's what you just said where did you
you said that why you said that you just
said your ex-wife you did you gave that
away it's doesn't even it airs tomorrow
you said your ex-wife gets killed
[Laughter]
well that just made what i said a few
minutes ago less harsh you know what
it's still a good show
you're gonna enjoy